[Music]
james is in philadelphia hey james
what's up
hey dave how's everything going better
than i deserve how can i help
good gun so dave i'm a current third
year podiatric medical student my wife
and i we're currently debt-free and we
have enough money to save for or we have
enough money saved that we can pay for
the rest of my tuition
but now with the current
politics and the environment that's
going on with the student loans and
what's going on with the federal
government we're now considering taking
out a loan for almost 50k student loan
and then using that money to invest
especially since there's zero interest
on federal student loans we would do
that with the option to pay that right
away off once the interest starts to
accrue
and then once student debt forgiveness
is officially off the table do you think
this is a smart decision in your eyes
so you're doing this in the hope that
you don't have to repay it
not necessarily
more or less we would invest it while
there is zero percent interest accruing
but if the off chance that student debt
does get forgiven we would basically
just
i mean save our back then because we
would be
a little bit disappointed if student
loans were forgiven when we paid out of
pocket all this time
okay
um
well a couple of breakdowns in that um
where you and i are not aligned and um
i'll walk through those with you because
you called and asked us okay
so the first thing is is um
i i'm not aligned that we
take out student loans with the hope
that they are forgiven uh because to me
that's like
taking money you weren't supposed to
take because you didn't need it and it's
kind of like i don't know
that feels like stealing to me okay
i'll just say it out loud and
the second thing is
borrowing money to invest
at a greater interest rate than the
money is costing you
has not proven to be something we found
in the data that causes people to become
wealthy so borrowing money to invest
is not the normative way
it's statistically unusual
as a way to build wealth what i mean is
when we study ten thousand 167
millionaires the number of millionaires
that borrowed money to invest
called arbitrage or playing margin
anytime you're borrowing money to invest
you could borrow money to buy real
estate uh you're borrowing money to
invest hoping that the investment is
going to create a greater rate of return
than the money cost you when you borrow
it the number of people that built
wealth doing that was way less than five
percent
meaning that 96 97 percent of the
millionaires we interviewed did not use
this process to become millionaires
now if i told you as a procedure in
medical school that you had a 97 failure
rate you would avoid that procedure
oh yeah definitely because the data
tells you that the facts tell you that
this methodology
is not successful but three or four
percent of the time
um and so you would avoid that
methodology and so i'm gonna tell you
not to borrow money and so what i'm
saying is what sounds smart on the
surface has not proven out to be the
typical way people build wealth
because what you're leaving out of the
equation is the risk situation and
you're adding stress you're adding
risk anytime you borrow money you add
risk the more money you borrow the more
risk you have
and that enters into the factor it
enters into relationships it enters into
mental wellness it enters into the
stress across the back of your neck
it enters into the stress around your
heart
it enters into the job you take because
you're in debt or not in debt i
understand you have the money in the
bank to pay it off so your level of risk
is relatively low compared to someone
that's playing you know borrowing the
money and going to vegas and has a
problem right i understand you're not
doing that i get that and and so i see
the logic and and how you got there but
um i'm just telling you the procedure
that you're using is not used
normatively by people who get the result
that you're looking for i would also say
that the logic is based on a hope and a
wish and i think it's just simply that
when i was growing up dave you'll
remember i'm 47 so all the 40-somethings
will remember this crazy
giant chicken named foghorn leghorn he
used to terrorize the bulldog in in that
cartoon he would put a stake on the end
of a fishing pole and he'd hold it out
in front of that bulldog and make that
bulldog just chase that steak and chase
that steak didn't know huh he didn't
know that he's been canceled
oh he has yeah the bulldog union oh is
that right i didn't know
i thought you were serious for a second
i was like did i really miss that
because anything's possible he just
killed my metaphor here's the deal
biden and the democrats are dangling
this policy out there yeah and i'm just
going to tell you this isn't a political
statement some of you will call it that
you can get over it later but i'm
telling you
that they are dangling that as a
possibility to garner votes they have
been in power before
they're in power right now they've done
what have they done what have they done
to you know and they've never they got
congress they got the senate they're not
going to do it here's why until until
october they got all three yeah if you
want to pass a law right now is the time
to pass it but they never have and they
never will here's why you go do the
research yourself folks that's big money
sallie mae freddie it is big money for
the federal government it has been since
they started the student loan program
way back in the late 50s early 60s and
replaced the pell grant this is a big
money play for the government they're
not going to forgive student loans ever
and i just think that if that wasn't a
potential you know kind of a stake out
there dangling in front of people
then they wouldn't be thinking about
this and i just got to tell you i don't
i don't mean to be the bearer of bad
news
they're not going to do it they've had
chances before this is not a new idea
this is not a new concept this is
recycled political jargon
and uh i wouldn't trust it for a second
yeah
well even if they do
it's still not right to your even if
they do i agree with that i agree i'm
borrowing money
the government gives it a you know it's
like saying that's like uh saying i'm
unemployed when i'm not yeah so that i
get unemployment or like saying
i'm broke so i get my welfare check even
though i'm making money on the table
all of those are theft all of those are
morally wrong
and
so i wouldn't do it for those reasons
but thank you for the call and
appreciate the discussion it's very very
good
i'll add one thing to this whole
discussion because it sounds like we're
somehow kind of uh self-righteous nyms
or something but again data okay the guy
who wrote a millionaire next door tom
stanley was a friend of mine before he
passed away wrote the book in 1992. he
wrote a follow-up book later of on deca
millionaires people that had 10 million
dollars or more he studied 38
characteristics he was a statistician
that was his background a marketing guy
and he studied 38 characteristics of the
people that became deca millionaires the
most correlated
of the different variables married
race
profession whatever
character qualities the most correlated
of all the 38 in all the deca
millionaires number one indicator you're
going to be a deca millionaire was
outlandish fanatical levels of integrity
you don't get that one very often this
is the ramsay show